all right so I have this integral I
already established it's a positive and
I've also established it can't just is
not unbounded doesn't it go forever
right it's going to be smaller than this
box that up around the blue box okay and
that area is read X do you hear that one
times your neck okay now I'm a this
reads thing which seems to come out of
there with but now I can work this thing
okay Zera is not much to do there but
this is reviewable we have just
established what this interval is equal
to right in this domain which is 40
positive
what's it equal to what's that what's
the primitive for that it comes from it
comes from log teeth right it's not log
negative T which were you talked about
last time why not it's because of the
domain that I'm interested in right like
look at where I'm integrating over all
the way over here I might even think
about this guy and then I've got this
down to this one brunettes
so far so good okay I've got my definite
digital it's been integrated I need to
evaluate now right so what am I going to
get on the inside jump
okay so I'll do the upper bound first
that's log of 3x and then I'm going to
evaluate the lower bound yep okay now
this is not exactly what I want right
have a look at what I'm trying to get
after not that far off they're not that
far off for starters what 1 log 1 is 0
this look carefully at it what I'm gonna
try and do to get it to nudge it closer
to what I want what what limit a magic
tranche of oh you know it's yeah okay I
can do I've got a powering this X to the
1/2 is it not right so that half that's
hiding up there can actually come out
the front right so this is really 0 1/2
log X square root of negative to do that
ok I'm almost there I'm so very close
right okay I'm gonna do break this thing
so multiply by 2 that will give me that
that's fine
I did not at first because two obviously
it doesn't muck around my inequalities
but I have to be careful with X right
can I multiply through by X now I'm just
going to pause for a second in this
context multiplying and dividing by X
either gonna be both be okay or both not
be okay right in my particular case I
don't really Morgan interested in
multiplication is division maybe the
same rules operate can I divide by X or
multiply man's the answer is in this
context I can write coz X is not just
anything where's it it's just positive
alright and yeah exactly right like I've
got a this is on the real plane right so
what you better believe I'm sticking a
positive number underneath the square
root
okay so therefore I can multiply I can
divide by X it doesn't violate any of my
inequalities yeah okay when I divide 0
by its what I get
well I want to live in that universe
that's amazing okay in here that's gonna
give me log X and then what do I get at
the inside you have to read acts on X I
could leave it in that form that's like
a wrap your lives tonight but I might as
well just write it as this and usually
we try not to have irrational
denominator right for the same reason we
usually train going negative denominator
but if you get that way we're going
right think about what I'm trying to
establish okay look I've got my mugger
tour next there in the middle so what is
left to do I need to take limits of
everything right that's what I've been
doing all the way through I've been
super playing if I need to do something
like x - I do it - one two three Limits
exactly the same right so humor me I'm
gonna take the limit as X approach
infinity of zero that's okay I'm going
to take the limit as X approaches
infinity of this guy in the middle and
then I'm gonna take the limit as X
approach infinity of X okay can you see
I'm pretty much there left-hand side of
the equality what happens to zero as X
approaches infinity stays at zero this
guy in the middle is actually what I'm
after so I'll just leave many years what
happens to that fraction 200 X as X
approaches in approaches zero as well
right like this is this is an even
clearer version of what we've done with
that intuition kid before here the
numerator is not even growing it's not
doing anything
and then the denominator is just getting
bigger and bigger I mean not
particularly fast but it's damn near
limit zero it has to be sure you've got
some number this limit in my middle
right ah I can't be less than zero
reading zero it's gonna be less than
zero now do you remember I actually took
that there's a fall listen look the last
time we're gonna use this right you have
this limit and it is being squeezed in
between two other things that are
behaving in this limiting behavior right
so therefore this thing yeah it must be
zero that's actually okay no no so so
remember remember the arguments that I
made right can it actually can this area
actually equal zero it really depends on
how I define things like if X right this
value here I suppose it X with equal to
1 1 then you're integrating from 1 to 1
so then it's I guess right but that kind
of she realizes what you're actually do
you I'm consuming areas that way areas
but I'll never have that circumstance
here we like this guy is never actually
going to come down and I'm many things
there's a discontinuity I can't go this
way all right so what are we just
established right um we've establish
what you told me what your intuition
told me but this is what it means to
prove something rigorously right and
sometimes we pulled on stuff like like
he's the critical step here like we use
this result of integration in a very
unexpected way by the integrations
happens with almost all kinds of things
and this is an example this is why
please don't just believe me when I told
you this
it's like cozy kind of you know that
that that why not well there's an actual
reason and it's actually a previously
proven just like everything about
um you know eggs thank you to be
constant then I do say that so X is no
more a constant then when you remember
this remember this right X here it's not
a closer the whole point is it can be
anywhere right I mean it is on this
curve but I can take anybody so that's
why you saw I couldn't really use I
didn't want to substitute X into itself
that would be a bit to you but it's just
the dummy variables I can using